one of them i could hear right now can
you hear him ah
he's loud
quiet
it sona fixes your life
hey guys it's sona and this is sona
fixes your life
i have twins
and so
they're still alive which means
i'm an expert at raising babies so
let's raise your kids musty glaciers
says how did you stay so trim after
having your babies
so something i found out is that you
burn calories just from producing breast
milk and i've been pumping since i had
babies so i'm burning calories just
sitting here right now otherwise
i would not be
trim at all also
i gave up the marijuana for a little
while and so i don't
eat a lot of
garbage like i used to
uh and i don't drink as much and uh i
have to stay somewhat healthy
so i just started losing weight who'd
have thought eating better you lose
weight
that's what i did but i don't know some
people like go to the gym and stuff i
don't do that yet
anyway you're welcome
stay trend you don't have to stay trim
also if you if you gain a lot of weight
like just embrace it
hula says
when do you have time to relax and do
things you like
that's funny you asked that because i
was like how am i gonna shoot this like
when am i gonna have time to shoot this
uh
but when do i do it like when i put them
to bed that's when i watch tv but you
know what there are days you guys
there's days when i'm like i remember
just sitting on my couch
all day from like the moment i woke up
to the moment i slept just watching
tv shows
and i'm never gonna have that again or
maybe not for another like i don't know
18 years
because like i have to do things like
parent then i realized i could just do
it when i
sleep like or when they sleep i guess
that's when i do it but i just
i mean like i would have watched like
seven shows during these last few months
since the show has been off the air i
would have watched like seven shows from
beginning to end it doesn't matter if
there were like eight seasons or two
seasons or whatever i would have just
done it
now i've i've watched one show i watched
one
um
they just require so much attention and
time i mean i love them so much
but yeah what do i have what was the
question what was the question when do
you have time to relax and do things you
like
right now i don't really but then you
can do it with them that's the thing i
do it with them and that's cool they're
really cute but it takes forever to
leave the house
so when do i have time to relax and do
things i like
you know what i don't i don't have time
i was trying to answer this question but
i'm like
i don't really know if i have time to do
that yet but i will that's what i know
you're welcome at sn 4 kp
4k says what temperature should i cook
them at
that 350 for 20 minutes
obviously
that's for medium rare
you're welcome
silly
[Music]